this is the technical difficulties and
playing citation needed join me today he
reads books you know it's Chris Joel
hello yeah everybody's favorite goes on
Gary's brother
yeah women like that like men like those
then why don't women like me singing on
the internet MacRay howdy YouTube uh in
front of me I've got an article from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fight we got right is a point and
a ding and the special prize for / -
good answers which is and today we are
talking about John Stone house did he
live in a green house completely against
type now is when you ding Tom no I can't
my folks know in any way no what's he a
bricklayer stone house no no he wasn't
he did go to work in a house and there's
a there's a capital H in that a house of
something card fun it'll repute I mean
you're pretty close to house of cards
Parliament yes have a point
oh yeah born in South Hampton educated
down the London School of Economics so
busy not to politicize ER and then he
went into politics under as the Labour
cooperative Member of Parliament see own
certain small supermarket from octopus
to gear engage everybody else shut up I
know the answer don't but you do still
have cooperative labor and pays in what
sense
no I'm not doing it pretty good and he
worked very closely to the Foreign
Office though is the Foreign Office the
Home Office the India Office and then
another one
Commonwealth oh no three Commonwealth
Empire half way between the two comp ire
places we stole office yeah
yes he became Minister for state for
technology and then took took a role I
was it going around people's houses
trying to sell cable yeah not from the
colonies are face-on oh he moved on from
that this this was with us in colonial
cable I've just realized we've not
actually touched on Telegraph yet and we
have to do that at least once twice to
see the house yes he became he became
Minister of the state for technology but
that meant he then transitioned into
what and this was in charge of
telecommunications as well as telegraphy
everything like that post office
Postmaster General you're both getting
the point
he was the Postmaster General of the
United Kingdom hell of a title yes he
was also the last Postmaster General of
the United King what did he do nothing
they're just all been really specific
since anything has general on the any
sounds great anyway he oversaw the
jamming of something a marmalade factory
there's this sort of jam war going on
you know just I'm holding toast at the
other yeah that's what was a grommet is
now we must stop this terrible conflict
to preserve
[Applause]
even the audience was half wouldn't want
people to end up normalized her 1970 he
oversaw the jamming of 70 1970 is it
pirate parody oh yeah I'll join the
point note was specifically what why is
it coming Luxembourg North Sea no you're
thinking Radio Luxembourg but no you're
absolutely right it's off in the North
Sea yeah this was one of the radio
Caroline's how was it all right see I
didn't say that because I thought it was
a leading question yeah this is 1qi
you allowed to go for that answer here
so he jammed Radio Caroline partly and
part of the response to that was that
Radio Caroline did what jammed them
right back no that actually would be not
illegal but its own will be I think
declaration of war if you do that to a
country and when it comes to boats we've
probably got the bigger shoe t yeah we
might have slightly more yeah because
Caroline was on and off for a bit yeah
off for a bit it was they they tried to
overcome the jamming obviously what were
they sending back over the airwaves
swear words yeah
filthy streams been evasive they could
have done their offshore
don't forget Radio Caroline wasn't
illegal they just made it so that any
British person associating with it was
breaking the law vote for the other ones
yes absolutely right they went political
and they started broadcasting pro
conservative propaganda back at them
sorry pi radio station pro broasted
broadcasting pro conservative messages
let that sink in for a minute
[Laughter]
yeah you wouldn't get that these days
would you lie mean no there's no pirate
radio stations yeah no they interfere
over the broadcaster's we are trying to
make it work and then we report the
Tawaf come and then they find them and
say no you're being naughty please don't
do that
see when you said deal with them that's
just did you somehow went round at night
with a bass grazers have a black ski
mask just comes out of the offices
Johnstone house still in charge of posts
and telecommunications in the 1970s
introduced what it's not established and
I think it is is it stamps second club
it's a good class now yeah absolutely
right first inside class time these all
seem fairly normal in 1970 he was he was
setting up various companies having
things on the side by 1974 most of these
were in financial trouble what he decide
to do print himself a whole book of
stamps as legal tender and pay off his
debt with a massive box full of stamps
that would have been a better plan than
the one he actually had issue a single
hundred and fifty thousand pound stamp
on the quiet to a collector also a
better plan than what he did Jesus
Christ robbed a bank with stamps did you
invent selfie stumps where you could
send in a selfie and you'd have your own
stamp he did separate on pirate radio
station didn't burn my sorry proper guys
in deep financial trouble here he's
doing creative accounting so he's gonna
be going to jail did he disappear uh
yeah a little bit more mats is he you is
it he faked his death yes he didn't is
he one of these clothes on the beach
guys and disappears bottom right oh
right he faked his death November 1974
leaving a pile of clothes on a Miami
Beach whose clothes his clothes um where
was he actually going Cuba Australia
that's a long swim nerd you one better
than me I was gonna say a long walk
without having quite stupid naked he's
gonna get cold is maybe Slaven himself
in goose fat beforehand and he'll he's
going the wrong way around is should
have gone from LA yeah man's a fool
because fat is what use them or I'm
rayon and that's what used for cross
channel to mean yeah when you're
swimming from Miami to Australia that's
what most people use their arms and like
to Gary Busey yeah it'll be fine this
Bub's Larry there's a breaker bar in the
goose fat segment projecting it from
behind loose fat hey goose gives out a
lot of fat you know he's just leaving
this greasy trail of notions greasy
Ocean Drive
hell of a series I was did a ghost at
Christmas and it put it put out a single
ghost now fairness I got it from a
budget supermarket so it may not have
been the very best of geese market so
geese Rotella yeah they just come from
the local pond and after no questions
tell no lies that's what I looked at it
but I did it and it pumped out half half
a liter of fat
it didn't even drip out it literally
just bleep you know your sings we get
oil wells and there's a gusher to the
channel a chance what nobody cried did
it deep fry itself oh you put it on on
an angle to let it all dried and he just
kept coming and coming coming it was all
big mincemeat job at Baker's half nearly
full of the goose fat no man in the
world could eat that much roast potatoes
is what I found
sorry can I just point out mincemeat jar
full of goose fat that's quite another
thing
so yes stone house meanwhile just try to
pull this back closer to tears than
laughter Gary because we'd had this
massive Christmas dinner where I've done
the goose I got all this goose fat you
know the holy grail of of Yorkshire
puddings and roasted house and in this
jar was Johnstone house she's seen worse
Johnstone house were was on route to
Australia setting up a new life with his
mistress and secretary and they two
separate people
was he just need a wee lass and taking
his mistress and his secretary who was
his new identity who's whose identity
taken on did he Nick a dead person's yes
he did deceased husband of a constituent
so he deposited cash one bank picked up
at another and the teller was suspicious
and report him to local police the
police when they interviewed him asked
him to drop his trousers Wow was the
person he was pretending to be a eunuch
no just his trousers if they're looking
for an identifying mark
are they not so tattoos or birthmark
neither this is 1974 Lord Lucan yes they
suspended them he was Lord Lucan who had
very famously disappeared there's a
whole separate story there someone
suspiciously turning up with an English
accent in Australia depositing large
sums of money who's obviously on the run
Lord Lucan had a large scar down his leg
so the police were going to drop me
trousers we want to see if your Lord
Lucan diddly-dee back himself in aid of
the cause if he did and he dropped his
trousers and there's no scar sure let go
of him ever again
yes he was still wasn't a story
it's thumbprint he's arrested six months
later he's deported to the UK
he's remanded in Brixton prison what is
he not done at any point during pull the
trousers up what really Wadley all the
way yeah Benson said I could he said
change his name back bear in mind his
job as Postmaster General X uh sorry
what was that Postmaster General ex post
messages he's still the same job had he
not been sacked yes he did not resign as
an MP oh boy did he come back to massive
fines for not having done his job
properly no oh
satire he just kept being an MP and
getting his salary but they still paying
him for the out the entire time he
buggered up well at this point he had to
have his trousers down cos the sheer
size of his ball he was put on trial on
21 charges of fraud theft forgery
conspiracies d fraud causing a false
police investigation and wasting police
tell sounds right for an MP
what became the novels small business
and put money in my safe it's got a back
on it more than 20 years after his death
something was revealed about him he was
lured Luton he just had a lot of guy I
was going for the button sister way way
back in his in his political career
he'd negotiation an agreement of
technological cooperation between
Britain and Czechoslovakia uh is he a
spy Oh
information sharing in Czechoslovakia
which is in the former Soviet bloc he's
not gonna just be in you know going and
eating their fine pastries is he yes it
turned out that he'd been agent for the
Czechoslovak Socialist Republic military
intelligence
he's postmaster generals yes post of a
Ryan I'm gonna give you a point for
tweaking that before I made fire
Czechoslovakia he was minister in charge
of post and Technology and that includes
things like the post office star and
things like that that are transmitting
signals around the world yes this is
pretty bad it is let's face it this is
bad news Beth and somehow the embezzling
and taking someone else that entity is
yet not the worst thing about this man
knows he's used to it yes true that at
the point where the government found out
about this Margaret Thatcher was in
power
what did she decide to do not privatize
him
yes he will know he will need more
efficiency as a privately owned scumbag
British politics jokes that well either
nothing or something is what I'm going
further tryst choose one of those
options I'm going with something you're
wrong it's nothing it was easier to
cover it up and never let the public in
hold up a bit of checks by in government
because they don't know yes
at the end of the show
congratulations Matt you in this one
power genuinely you've got a lot of
things in there are you in breakfast
food prepared by the star of Sherlock
it's eggs benedict cumberbatch do you
enjoy that with that we say thank you to
Chris Joel to go running tomorrow above
a YouTube open tongue Scott we'll see
you next time
you